thanks to curiositystream for supporting
this episode go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos to start streaming thousands
of documentaries
and for a special offer that helps
support our show
[Music]
if you've been following along with us
lately you probably know
that we are pretty excited about our
latest microscope upgrades and
can you blame us it's like having a new
toy that is
actually a spaceship it's pretty hard to
shut up about something that is shiny
and new and also takes you into a whole
new world
and that's kind of what it feels like to
see our familiar friends at this
magnification
even though we've seen tardigrades many
times before in so many different ways
we have not seen them like this
and bringing this level of magnification
gives us a new layer
of the microcosmos to explore it's like
we've descended
into a new level of a cave getting
further from our world
though fortunately for the easily scared
among us the cave is metaphorical and
the risks
are negligible all we need for the
journey are some objective lenses
and a tiny drop of oil
yeah oil but to explain
what oil does we're gonna have to get a
little bit technical first because yes
we love our microbes
but we're only able to see them thanks
to light and light
is complicated but we need to give it
its do
so let's start with the objective lens
the main job of the objective lens is to
take
light leaving the sample and focus it
into an image
for us to see and there are two main
numbers
that describe an objective lens the
first one's pretty obvious
it's the magnification but the
magnification you see
written on the objective lens is not the
same as the magnification we write up in
the corner of the videos
that's because the objective lens isn't
the only source of magnification in our
microscope
we're also looking through an eyepiece
that has its own magnification so the
final magnification that we see
is the product of the objective lenses
and the eyepieces
magnifications now we don't usually do
math on this channel but this is one of
the rare cases where the math
and optics are straightforward in our
microscope
the eyepiece has a magnification of 10x
so if we're looking through a 63x
objective
the final magnification is 630x
and that is the number you'll see in the
corner
but you should never trust an optics
lesson that seems
simple how could it be when the image
we're seeing
is the product of so many things
at once some tangible like a lens
others much less so
and what is less tangible than light
which is as we've seen before on this
channel
a very strange thing
we cannot touch it but we can manipulate
it
using what we know of the way it travels
and bends and reflects
to see our world differently but
light has its limits
the thing about making things larger is
that at some point it's not enough to
just
zoom in you need to be able to capture
the detail
that's there and this leads us to the
second important number you will find on
an objective lens
the numerical aperture unlike
magnification numerical aperture's
probably not super self-explanatory
what the number describes is the ability
of the objective
to take in light as light travels
from the sample and to the objective it
radiates
outward like a cone and the higher your
numerical aperture the wider
the cone of light that's going into your
objective
and that allows for more rays to enter
the objective from all sorts of
different angles
helping to illuminate more details and
give greater resolution to your final
image
but of course not still not all that
goes into capturing the perfect
microscopic image
let's take a look at this glaucoma
spinning around at a thousand
x magnification it's visible and you can
see some of the details
it looks fine but let's take a look at
it again here
same glaucoma same objective same level
of magnification
what was fine before now looks dull in
comparison
to the image we were seeing before with
the detailed striations and vivid
pockets of green on the glaucoma's body
to get from one of these images to the
other james our master of microscopes
didn't change any of the technical
settings on his microscope or pull some
kind of video editing wizardry
he just simply added a drop of oil to
the coverslip
encasing the glaucoma and then dipped
the objective
into the oil now this is because
the cone of light going from the
specimen
into the objective isn't just going
straight from the sample
to the lens it's passing through
something
it's passing through air
light travels at different speeds in
different materials
and when it changes from material to
material it will bend
this is called refraction and materials
like oil
slow light down more and that matters to
our microscope
because it gives us the wider cone of
light that we need to get a higher
numerical aperture
whether we've got air between the sample
and the lens or oil when we're viewing
our samples
depends on the objective we're looking
through our lower magnification
objectives
have lower numerical apertures and
they're meant to be used with air
our higher magnification objectives have
higher numerical apertures and they are
meant
to be used with oil using air with oil
objectives gives us
poor images and using oil with our dry
objectives would
damage the objective so don't do that
the numerical aperture and its
relationship to resolution is important
because it puts a limit on just how much
magnification we can actually do
with a given objective there's a general
estimate if you're looking into
microscopy yourself
that you'll get a good magnification
when you're working in the range that's
500 to 1000 times
the numerical aperture of the objectives
so our 100x objective
and 1.3 numerical aperture can reach a
maximum
of 1300x magnification depending on your
eyepiece
with our 10x eyepiece we get 1000x
magnification
and it works great but if we tried to
get more from this setup by increasing
the magnification of our eyepiece to 20x
we could not actually get 2000 x
magnification
because of the constraints of our
numerical aperture
we would just be losing half of the
image without actually gaining more
detail in what's left to see but that's
what happens
anytime we want to take an image we have
to make a decision
between what we can and cannot see
there are always choices that have to be
made
and details that have to be lost we
simply cannot see
all of the world in all its entirety all
at once
but we can see more of it by tracking
the choices we make
as we dive deeper choices in techniques
and materials that affect what we can
see
and how we see it and enrich the story
further
even when those choices impose
constraints
at some point in history we wanted to
see more
and lenses with their magnificent
manipulation of light
have helped us do that we've used them
to see light
from distant stars and to peer into the
most mundane surroundings
on earth and whatever image has come
back to us
has brought the universe closer to view
even if it's just
infractions
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us this episode was
brought to you
by curiositystream a subscription
streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction tv shows from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including award-winning exclusives and
originals
they cover topics like history nature
science
food technology travel and more there
you can watch the documentary series
ancient yellowstone where scientists
discuss how the distribution of
microbial life in extreme environments
here on our planet
can give us a better idea of where in
the universe
life might be able to exist you can
stream curiosity streams library
including their collections of curated
programs hand-picked by their experts to
any device
for viewing anytime anywhere and if you
go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos and use the word microcosmos
to sign up
it will only cost you 14.99
for an entire year the people you're
seeing on the screen right now
those are our patreon patrons they are
the people
who help make this show possible if you
like it
they are the ones to thank and i am
feeling very grateful for them
today as they allow us to look deeper
not just in magnification but also
in resolution if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and also i think tick tock now
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you